bonsoir nous sommes jeudi 5 février
merci de nous rejoindre dans file echo
l'émission qui revient sur votre
actualité économique local on commence à
citer avec les titres de cette édition
dans le département comme partout en
france le secteur du commerce est en
constante évolution et les communes
doivent s'adapter
nous verrons le bilan mais aussi des
nouvelles dynamiques du commerce dans
les yvelines l'a dit c'est l'association
pour le droit à l'initiative économique
à l'occasion de sa 11e semaine du
microcrédit de nouveaux entrepreneurs
accompagnés par l'association ou
détériorés récompensé versailles
ils nous parleront de la vie en fin
d'émission nous découvrirons le métier
de parfumeur nous avons rencontré des
étudiants de l'isie pas une des écoles
françaises qui forment les jeunes aux
métiers de la parfumerie de la
cosmétique et de la rom
elle se trouve dans les yvelines nous y
sommes allés enfin la 19e semaine de
l'emploi a lieu à saint quentin en
yvelines cela commence demain vendredi
nous en parlerons avec notre invité
bonjour jean luc berho vous êtes
directeur de la maison de l'entreprise à
saint quentin en yvelines nous en
parlerons avec vos dons de cette dix
neuvième semaine de l'emploi
mais avant cela passe en revue
l'actualité de la semaine
je vous le disais en titre petits
commerces ou grands centres commerciaux
leur impact sur l'économie chinoise est
primordial mardi matin la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de versailles
yvelines
organiser une grande conférence pour
évoquer le futur des commercy vinoy au
coeur de cette rencontre
l'évolution et les tendances du commerce
ainsi que la réglementation sur
l'urbanisme commercial
regardez ce reportage réalisé avec
elodie moines avec 16000 boutiques et
deux des trois plus grands centres
commerciaux d'île de france
le secteur du commerce tient une place
importante dans les yvelines
pourtant depuis la crise les modes de
consommation ont changé en france la
fréquentation a baissé de 10% dans les
magasins les clients délaissent les
commerces de proximité et les centres
commerciaux pour les enseignes
installées en périphérie sur les 262
commune yvelinoise seuls 110 compte plus
de dix commerces
nous on a voulu surtout alerter les
collectivités parce que certaines
n'étaient absolument pas ne se rendait
pas compte c'est quand on s'aperçoit
qu'à des friches commerciales qui
apparaissent de plus en plus c'est là où
les collectivités le maire font appel à
la chambre en te disant qu'est ce qui se
passe lorsqu'un coeur de ville commence
aussi à dépérir il y en a de plus en
plus objectif faire un état des lieux et
les évolutions sont nombreuses parmi
elles un fort développement des parcs
d'activités commerciales de plus de 5000
m² et des centres outlet trois centres
commerciaux de ce type ont vu le jour
dans le département depuis 2009
du côté de l'alimentaire les
supermarchés se développe aussi mais
seulement dans des communes de 4000 à
6000 habitants redensifier les
centres-villes et pourtant une priorité
mais la difficulté liée aux réforme de
l'urbanisme commercial freine nombre de
communes et empêchent parfois cette
dynamique il faut être très prudent dans
la bonne cohérence de tout ce qu'on
écrit dans un document d'urbanisme et
l'absence de contradiction entre les
dispositions sont des documents très
lourd à écrire très volumineux et c'est
un travail vraiment d'orfèvre qu'il faut
faire en la matière l'évolution des
règles et de la législation de
l'implantation des commerces des données
importantes pour les élus locaux
venus nombreux à cette conférence la
chambre de commerce cherche avant tout à
leur donner une vision d'ensemble du
territoire l'élu local il va
essentiellement regarder sa ville et son
périmètre et ils ne voient pas tout ce
qu'il ya autour et tous les projets dont
qui va construire son projet pour sa
ville et ses habitants
par contre il trouve tout se passe aussi
autour de lui et ça il n'en a pas
forcément la vision doit quand même une
vision panoramique de ce qu'il ya sur le
département est relativement important
au niveau de deux des yvelines pour
permettre justement une croissance et un
maintien de toutes les offres de
commerce possible sur le territoire
un enjeu de taille pour les communes et
le département
en 2012 le commerce représente et 17,8
pour cent des nombreux salariés dont les
civils cette semaine l'a dit
l'association pour le droit à
l'initiative économique organisé sa
grande campagne pour faire parler du
microcrédit dans ce cadre 20 créateurs
d'entreprise accompagnés par
l'association et qui ont bénéficié
justement du microcrédit ont reçu des
trophées solidaire offert en partenariat
avec le rotary club de versailles
l'événement a eu lieu mardi à versailles
l'occasion de revenir sur l'action de
l'adie regarder une petite récompense
mais un vrai coup de pouce pour ces
nouveaux entrepreneurs
hier 20 créateurs d'entreprise yvelinois
accompagné par l'adie l'association pour
le droit à l'initiative économique ont
été distingués ils ont tous bénéficié de
l'aide de l'association pour le droit à
l'initiative économique et de son micro
crédit grâce à ce lâcher rima a pu
investir dans du matériel pour
développer son activité
je serais content d'avoir découvert l'a
dit parce que ça m'a permis de me lancer
rapidement d'avoir confiance en moi et
aussi le fait d'avoir quelqu'un au sud
soit à qui on peut parler en cas de
problème donc c'est toujours rassurant
ensuite ça m'a permis de me découvrir
maintenant je veux vraiment me
développer dans le milieu l'événementiel
la photo c'est ce que je fais maintenant
et j'aimerais tout était bouclé
meurt il y à des sites internet on est
sur leur site ils me font de la
publicité
ils ont beaucoup de contacts il ya
d'autres aides financières à côté qui
sont aussi très facile quand on commence
ça tombait à pic en cadeau un ordinateur
tablette outil indispensable pour un
chef d'entreprise
une récompense offerte par le rotary
club de versailles s'engager auprès de
l'adie et récolter des fonds c'est avant
tout pour soutenir l'entrepreneuriat
social dans les yvelines
les chefs d'entreprise les dirigeants
d'entreprises ont eu un tout petit peu
plus de chance que d'autres dans la vie
et donc il ya une bonne logique à
restituer un petit peu de cette chance
et donc on a souhaité l'accompagner et d
une association ayant une vocation
véritablement aider les gens à sortir de
situations compliquées et c'est vraiment
le rôle de l'adie créé en 1989 l'adie
apporte avec son micro crédit un soutien
important aux jeunes entrepreneurs qui
ne peuvent prétendre un crédit bancaire
traditionnel
en 25 ans elle a financé plus de 143
milles microcrédit et participé à plus
de cent mille créations d'entreprises
françaises
il se lance on les finance mais aussi on
les accompagne
parce que dans la vie d'un chef
d'entreprise il ya des moments qui sont
difficiles mais aussi des moments on a
besoin d'un appui par exemple pour des
démarches commerciales reconnues
d'utilité publique l'association est
aujourd'hui un acteur majeur dans le
financement des micro entreprises en
2013 l'adie a créé chaque semaine 200
nouveaux emplois et financé 14000
personnes
pourtant son action reste encore peu
connues pour y remédier l'association
organise chaque année depuis 2005 la
semaine du microcrédit afin de
sensibiliser de potentiels bénéficiaires
dans une période de chômage comme on a
maintenant avec des durées de chômage
qui sont de plus en plus longues
c'est important effectivement se poser
la question à un moment donné est-ce que
je continue dans ma recherche d'emploi
salarié ou est ce que finalement j'ai
pas les moyens de me lancer à mon compte
et de créer mon propre emploi donc c'est
ces personnes là qu'on va aider
après deux ans d'activité le taux de
pérennité des entreprises aidées et de
70 % et le taux d'insertion des
personnes financées de 84 % au niveau
national dans le département des
yvelines
l'adie est une centaine de personnes
chaque année vous vous êtes déjà demandé
où aller pour faire vos courses et payer
le moins cher alors cette étude publiée
par l'ufc que choisir devrait vous
intéresser
pendant deux semaines de fin septembre à
début octobre l'année dernière
l'association a empiété sur les prix
dont plus de 3800 magasins de france
dont chacun de 80 produits ont été
relevés et comparer résultats dans les
yvelines
celle enseigne leclerc à beaune à
recycler la palme du magasin le moins
cher avec un panier moyen de 350 en
euros contre 377 au niveau national
écoutez ces précisions avec le président
de l'union à versailles au micro
d'hélène thorez 2014 par un pro 2013 à
une baisse de 0 7%
donc l'ensemble des produits a diminué
et notamment les produits laitiers
ce que l'on constate quand même c'est
qu'il y ait des écarts et les écarts
sont très faibles entre eux entre les
enseignes et donc aussi là où il ya déjà
au casino il ya un net progrès et même
dans certains endroits ces îles sont
avant il se classera avant de jijel et
géant casino pour les enseignes casino
pour connaître le classement précis des
enseignes près de chez vous rendez vous
sur le site internet de l'association
vous y trouverez une carte interactive
consultable gratuitement 2015 est
l'année du changement pour parler d'eux
en plus d'avoir un nouveau directeur
jonathan tout le monde
le centre commercial inauguré en 1969 a
atteint 20 années sa 4e phase de travaux
dix mille mètres carrés supplémentaires
vont voir le jour il accueillera une
trentaine de boutiques supplémentaires
en plus de 190 commerce actuel des 190
commerce actuel pardon un nouveau cinéma
est également en projet d'une capacité
de 1700 sièges il devrait regrouper neuf
salles les travaux devraient s'achever
en 2017
il est maintenant temps de parler
d'emploi avec notre entretien de la
semaine c'est tout de suite
l'événement commence demain du 6 au 14
février l'agglomération de saint quentin
en yvelines organise sa dix neuvième
semaine de l'emploi pour en parler avec
nous au plateau jean luc berho vous êtes
je le rappelle le directeur de la maison
entreprise de saint quentin en yvelines
depuis sa création en 2000 alors l'aise
en entreprise est un acteur important
dans cette semaine alors je vous
demandais tout d'abord comment comment
est née cette initiative de la semaine
de l'emploi la semaine de long peut
d'abord une initiative de la
collectivité territoriale du sein à
l'époque qui souhaitaient fédérer et
mobiliser l'ensemble des acteurs
économiques plus particulièrement ceux
qui travaillent autour de l'emploi pour
les mettre en avant
fédérer un peu leur action et rendre
leur démarche un peu plus accessible au
public de 50 ans alors pourquoi c'est
l'agglomération acquis et s'occupe
justement de cette initiative de la
mettre en place le rôle d'une
collectivité c'est aussi un rôle de
facilitateur et de mobilisateur des
forces vives qui composent son
territoire
donc le rôle n'est pas de se substituer
justement ses compétences mais de l'est
de les fédérer de les mobiliser des
c'est d'organiser autour d'elle un
certain nombre d'événements pour rendre
à la fois lisible et complémentaires
leurs actions au bénéfice des demandeurs
d'emploi en tout cas pour ce qui est la
semaine de l'emploi est ce que justement
parents d'emploi il ya une nouvelle
dynamique au niveau de l'agglomération
peut-être des nouvelles initiatives qui
vont être mises en place
alors le projet que porte les élus du
territoire et une logique de fusion des
structures pour optimiser les
compétences et les rendre aussi un peu
plus lisible notamment auprès des
personnes à la fois chef d'entreprise et
la fois public demandeur d'emploi donc
nous travaillons actuellement sur
rassemblement des compétences que
peuvent composer la maison de
l'entreprise de maison de l'emploi la
cité des métiers en particulier et ce
rassemblement de compétences vous savez
après ce que ça va donner de la tête une
idée validée en tout cas c'est d'être
d'avoir en un lieu unique entre
guillemets sous forme de guichet unique
ses compétences rassemblées pour surtout
favorisé la venue des entreprises leur
permettre d'avoir un accès plus rapide
plus directe optimisée de ses
compétences alors revenons sur sur le
forum de l'emploi donc elle va y avoir
des ateliers il va y avoir des forums il
va y avoir
voilà des entreprises qui vont se
présenter pour recruter est-ce que vous
avez justement décidé de mobiliser des
acteurs locaux essentiellement pour le
salon tous les acteurs locaux sont
mobilisés autour la semaine de l'emploi
en fonction des différentes actions qui
vont ponctuer cette semaine il était
vraiment d'avoir des ancrages locaux
pour avoir un accès direct à permettre
aux à la fois aux entreprises et aux
publics en recherche d'emploi d'avoir
localement et à proximité un maximum de
services donc pour les forums en
particulier effectivement nous avons
rassemblé des entreprises locales
alors comment quand vous les avez
sollicité l ont répondu enfin
positivement sa et à s'effacer ça s'est
mis en place facilement pour la mise en
place n'est jamais simple l'idée était
vraiment de mobiliser des entreprises
qui ont des ambitions de recrutements
dans un contexte particulièrement
compliqué en ce moment et l'idée a été
effectivement d'orienter ce forum sur
des secteurs d'activité qui recrutent
qui ont des difficultés souvent de
recrutement donc on a préféré jouer la
la qualité plutôt que la quantité
puisque sur deux nous aurons des forums
thématiques tout cas pour cette année
dans le cadre de la semaine de l'emploi
l'idée de reconduire peut-être sur
l'année un certain nombre de formes
identiques mais sur les thématiques
différentes
il ya un forum qui a trait à cibler
pense notamment au forum du recrutement
alors ils concernent le secteur du
transport et la logistique du commerce
de la restauration et de la distribution
donc c'est un choix si oui qu'est-ce qui
se cache derrière ces mots ou est-ce
qu'il ya quel métier quelle entreprise
voilà se cache derrière ce forum
principalement des petites et moyennes
entreprises qui sont d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui les entreprises qui
recrutent
c'est vrai que le public pense que enfin
a tendance à s'orienter majoritairement
vers les grandes entreprises
or on sait qu'en france l'emploi ce sont
principalement les tpe et les pme 500 pu
les croiser entreprises les gros groupes
qui sont en demande qui recherchent si
il ya toujours des recherches sur des
profils particuliers en fonction de la
nature d'activité
mais ce qu'on oublie souvent ce que
l'emploi aujourd'hui est caractérisé
principalement par la recherche de très
petites et moyennes entreprises
pourtant quand on voit la situation avec
les tpe les pme que c'est un peu
compliqué en ce moment par la loma kron
des manifestations je pense pas aux
travaux publics
elles recrutent toujours il ya toujours
eu un phénomème peut-être juste assez
ciblées à saint quentin ou dans notre
bassin d'agglomération ou sur toute la
france donc s'il ya 50 un homme on ne
peut raisonner vraiment secteurs
d'activité je le disais à l'instant des
secteurs d'activités qui sont notamment
visés dans le cadre du forum du
recrutement sont des secteurs qui ont
vraiment des difficultés on parlait du
commerce les stands les transports parce
que peut-être poser du public on n'est
pas sur des emplois qui sont valorisants
et puis le contexte de la tpe pme peut
parfois laisser penser qu'il ya peu de
perspectives d'évolution lorsqu'on
intègre une entreprise de petite taille
or finalement se rend compte que c'est
peut-être aujourd'hui davantage dans ces
entreprises de tailles modestes que les
perspectives d'évolution sont
intéressantes et s'étend aux emplois
qualifiés qu'on propose c'est de la
destination de tous au tout public
absolument vous qui travaillez avec les
entreprises locales
est-ce que voilà c'est important de
faire de faire travailler sur lequel
beaucoup d'entreprises sont implantées
donc dans les yvelines est-ce que du
coup il ya une spécificité à notre
département par rapport à ça après la
recherche d'emploi vous voulez parler de
la nature d'activité des entreprises
concernées principalement sur un secteur
tertiaire mais aujourd'hui 50 ha on est
en est la preuve
on a quand même une diversité
d'activités le secteur industriel sur 50
ha et représenter le secteur artisanal
les aussi puisque sur sur plus de 7000
entreprises
on a un put de on a plus de 1000
entreprises qui sont de nature
artisanale donc on a une diversité
d'activités sur notre notre territoire
ce qui ont fait la richesse c'est ce qui
permet d'avoir un secteur un tissu
économique équilibré il ya justement des
des ateliers dédiés aux dirigeants qui
sont organisées par la maison
entreprises donc c'est le 10 février il
ya deux ateliers un matin à l'après midi
alors il ya ismail sont intitulé comment
bien recruté justement on s'imagine pas
que les employeurs peuvent avoir des
difficultés par rapport à ça vous leur
apportez des solutions parce qu'il ya
une demande
ils ont du mal à recruter ils savent pas
comment gérer l'europe ça peut sembler
paradoxal c'est vrai qu'on a à la fois
un public recherche et l'emploi mais
aussi et c'est important un nombre
important d'entreprises qui ne n'arrive
pas à recruter donc une inadéquation je
dire entre l'offre et la demande et
notre rôle à nous c'est d'essayer d'être
un intermédiaire un relais un
facilitateur je le verrai tout à l'heure
entre ces deux partis que peuvent être à
la foux l'employeur et l'employé
potentiel donc dans le cadre de cette
démarche là on va proposer aux
entreprises qui le souhaitent de
réfléchir sur un certain nombre d'outils
qu'on peut tester en difficulté elle
rencontre les ont du mal à recruter
c'est parce qu'il ya un lien leur profil
comment ça se passe alors le la cible
effectivement est importante
je pense qu'il vaut mieux viser
effectivement le un nombre restreint de
demandeurs d'emplois potentiels plutôt
qu'un nombre volumineux et ne pas
trouver son bonheur dans une liste
importante en revanche ce qu'il faut
quand même savoir c'est que pour des
activités spécifiques notamment j'y
reviens mais les petites et moyennes
entreprises
elles ont parfois du mal à avoir des
candidatures qui correspondent
précisément à ces postes
parce que le public n'est pas forcément
intéressés par l'emploi dans les petites
et moyennes entreprises
on parle beaucoup en ce moment des
entrepreneurs vous accompagnez aussi des
jeunes entrepreneurs
en ce moment c'est à paris le salon de
l'entrepreneur a également exclu
peut-être la solution pour trouver un
emploi ce serait de monter sa propre
entreprise
ça peut être une solution mais tout le
monde ne peut pas créer et diriger une
entreprise c'est aujourd'hui une
vocation avant tout en revanche une
chose est sûre c'est que une petite
entreprise qui se montent dans de bonnes
conditions à de vrais un gros potentiel
de développement nous en tant que
collectivité que collectivité et outils
mis en place par la collectivité notre
rôle d'une part de les aider à se créer
mais aussi et surtout tirée de favoriser
la pérennité de ces entreprises pour
leur permettre d'embaucher mais ce qui
permet une embauche c'est avant tout
l'activité économique et le carnet de
commandes
une dernière question pour les gens qui
voient la désirait se rendre justement à
nos ateliers au forum quels conseils
donneriez-vous parce que je pense que
peut-être certains sont un petit peu
effrayé ce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
vont venir à ces forums c'est va venir
avec son cv qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
place à et confié les clés anti voeux
pour que ce soit une opération bénéfique
d'abord de se préparer parce que quand
on a l'opportunité d'avoir un échange
avec un dirigeant d'entreprise ou un
recruteur quel qu'il soit c'est
l'occasion avant tout peut-être en talk
show de se tester de tester son discours
face un professionnel du recrutement
donc même si les changes n'aboutit pas à
court terme il peut éventuellement
aboutir à moyen terme
mais voilà avant toute chose se prépare
et se mettre en condition et puis être
précis dans ses attentes pour ici de
favoriser le la relation avec la
personne qui seront face de vous bien
merci à jean luc mélenchon pour pour ses
conseils mais a refusé de venir sur le
plateau pour répondre à nos questions je
propose de continuer maintenant notre
émission avec le chiffre de la semaine
2000 c'est le nombre de personnes
attendues pour cette dix neuvième
semaine de l'emploi alors ce chiffre
n'est pour l'instant qu'une estimation
les temps forts de cette semaine seront
donc le forum de formations métiers le 6
et 7 février et le forum de recrutement
le mardi 10 février il devrait attirer
le plus de visiteurs je vous propose de
passer maintenant notre parti et
magazines avec notre dossier de la
semaine
cette semaine nous vous proposons un
dossier spécial dans notre magazine sur
le métier donné nous allons parler du
métier de parfumeur créateur
peu d'écoles proposent ce cursus est
l'une d'elles
et dans les yvelines à versailles isipca
c'est l'institut supérieur international
du parfum de la cosmétique et de
l'aromatique alimentaire
elles forment aux métiers de la
parfumerie et des cosmétiques des jeunes
venus de toute la france
nous avons rencontré ces parfumeur
débutants ou expérimentés ils nous ont
parlé de leur métier regardez ces images
de william l
romain respini pour le montage c'est ici
que naissent les les parmi ces étudiants
affairés dans ce laboratoire se cache
peut-être un futur jean paul guerlain
attention à l'euro à cette heure n'est
pas soluble dans l'alcool je pense que
vérifier mais à mon avis il a dû reposer
chez tout le monde dirait qu'ils ont
fait dans d'autres solvants
ces jeunes sont des élèves de l'isipca
l'école est une référence dans ce
secteur la famille guerlain présent créé
dans le département a créé l'école en
1970 ça versailles
quelques années plus tard c'est à orphin
près de rambouillet que sont fabriqués
tous les parfums de la marque
l'école accueille 460 étudiants
majoritairement en cursus apprentissage
chaque année 20 élèves sortent diplômés
du master professionnel formulation et
évaluation sensorielle option parfumerie
ont fait 9 actions à prix matières
premières comment elles sont extraites
d'où elles viennent
on a aussi des des cours sur
l'évaluation enfin tous les métiers liés
à la partie mais on a aussi des cours
chimie à la fac on a des examens sur les
matières premières consent donc sentir
300 au bout de deux ans doit les
connaître par coeur leur fiche
descriptive suivant c'est l'entraînement
vu qu'on fait ça toutes les semaines
tous les jours
au programme de ce cours de travaux
pratiques reproduire à l'identique un
célèbre parfum d'une grande marque à
l'aide de différentes essences sont
préparés
une matière première à 10 % parce qu'en
fait on utilise des matières premières
et c'est 10% pour avoir un rendu tout
huit élèves de créances pour se lancer
dans cette filière de solides notions
scientifiques sont nécessaires une
licence de chimie ou son équivalent
s'est demandée pour intégrer le master
enseigné en partenariat avec
l'université de versailles saint quentin
la partie scientifique en fait nous
permet de savoir en fonction de l'emploi
de différentes matières premières si
comment ça va réagir si on va voir des
problèmes de coloration de stabilité
c'est là où la partie scientifique
l'interview si la formation est
accessible sur concours mais pas de test
sur le nez les qualités olfactives ne
rentre pas encore en compte à ces
niveaux
quand on veut faire ce métier là où se
curent sur cela c'est parce qu'on est
passionné par le milieu de la parfumerie
donc inconsciemment on a commencé déjà
avoir des réflexes à sentir des matières
foire en fait pas sentir des matières
premières mais à reconnaître des parfums
sortir des parents s'intéresser un petit
pas tous qui s'est créé dans les
dernières années
connaître les différents top 10 de
chaque année est aussi savoir comment se
porte le marché
une fois le mélange réaliser l'exercice
est fini il est temps de passer sous le
nez de sylvie jour des professeurs et
parfumeuse elle va juger si les essences
créer son fidèle au modèle original vont
sentir voir nos erreurs
étonnant que ce soit parfait des
premiers essais et corriger leurs
erreurs donc on les laisse vous faire
eux-mêmes pour qu'ils apprennent aussi
l'esprit critique voir quelles sont les
matières premières qui sont surdosage
qu'est-ce qu'on a bien rattrapé comme
facettes qu'est-ce qu'on a moins bien de
travailler
on n'a pas trop côté fruité
très rose et le monde du parfum est un
milieu assez confidentielle si les
vocations sont nombreuses peu d'élèves
de vienne n'est il en existe cinq cents
à travers le monde et moins d'une
centaine en france tous les élèves qui
se trouvent ici sont pas forcément
destiné au métier de parfumeur
d'abord parce que c'est un métier assez
assez peu courant et ne marchait
pourrait pas absorber 20 étudiants et en
plus tous n'ont pas les qualités
requises
même si en bandeau pour être
parfaitement les qualités requises un
parfumeur c'est la créativité c'est
l'imagination c'est bien sûr la
connaissance des matières premières et
des mécanismes de formulation à la
sortie de leur master ces jeunes seront
recrutés dans les six mois
principalement dans la parfumerie
fonctionnel le contrôle la gestion et la
législation des matières premières
créateur de parfum n'est pas l'unique
débouché de ce cursus mais certains ne
devienne comme si les jours des jeux
ramène les formules une fois qu'elles
sont qu'elles sont écrites je les ramène
à coralie qui elle va se charger en
fonction de ce qui est écrit et des
matières premières qu'elle a à sa
disposition de peser cette formule
elle a étudié à l'institut supérieur
international du parfum de la cosmétique
et de l'aromatique alimentaire avant d'y
enseigner la parfumeuse a longtemps
travaillé dans de grandes maisons avant
de créer son propre laboratoire d'abord
alou sienne puis à paris moi je
travaille pour des marques différentes
personnalités qui viennent me demander
un parfum pour leur propre marque
donc il ya tout d'abord un gros travail
pour comprendre ce que les gens
souhaitent pour qu'ils veulent
travailler comment quel est leur image
de leurs marques leurs personnalités
la personnalité des parfums les étapes
avant la création sont primordiales et
demande beaucoup d'imagination et de
créativité des qualités essentielles
pour année je compare toujours avec la
musique ou j'imagine je ne suis pas
musicienne à mon grand regret avec un
compositeur de musique il entend d'abord
sa mélodie avant de poser les notes sur
sur sa portée avant de les jouer et bien
nous c'est un petit peu la même chose on
sent en
on entend notre notre mais audi
olfactives et on va choisir les matières
premières les plus appropriés pour
arriver à rendre ce que l'on imaginé
sylvie travaille de plus en plus sur la
communication olfactive de nombreuses
marques souhaitent avoir leur propre
identité et l'odeur qui les caractérise
pour améliorer leurs techniques
marketing
une nouveauté qui se développent et
pourrait apporter un nouvel élan dans ce
milieu en france le secteur de la
parfumerie se porte bien mais évoluent
peu en 2014
il a enregistré 0,2 pour cent de
croissance et 1,9 milliard d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires et si les métiers de
la parfumerie de la cosmétique ou de la
rom vous intéresse sachez que l'isi pia
ouvre ses portes ce week-end donc le
samedi 7 février de 9h à 10h plus
d'informations sur le site internet
www.caf.fr passons maintenant à notre
agenda la semaine
cette semaine notre agenda concerne la
19e semaine de l'emploi le premier temps
fort de cette semaine c'est le forum de
la formation aux métiers ouverts de 9h à
12h et de 13h30 à 16h30
il ya lieu au pavillon waldeck-rousseau
à billancourt des représentants des
différents établissements de formation
seront présents
vous vous aider dans la construction
d'un parcours d'orientation le 6 et le 6
février est réservée aux établissements
scolaires sur inscription et le samedi 7
février est ouvert à tout public
le deuxième événement important c'est le
forum du recrutement il a lu le mardi 10
février de 9 heures à 13 heures c'est un
forum cible et où vous pouvez rencontrer
une vingtaine de professionnels dans les
secteurs du transport de la logistique
du commerce mais aussi de la
distribution et de la restauration
pensez à amener votre cv ou à
l'améliorer s'il est déjà fait
c'est la fin de notre émission merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous souhaite une
très bonne soirée je vous donne rendez
vous la semaine prochaine pour un
prochain numéro de l'écho